now today during Biden's half-hearted
attempt to commemorate 911 during the
pit stop in Alaska after his disastrous
pressure in Vietnam the president rushed
through a short-toned deaf speech
playing down the threat of Al Qaeda
while emphasizing the rise of political
extremism really take a look
Governor John Levy it's good to see you
cover and I have something in common
we're both from Scranton Pennsylvania
I wish I had him playing in my high
school ball club that I was playing
but I would have could have been an
All-American have you in front of me
terrorism including political and
ideological violence is the opposite of
all we stand for as a nation
that settles our difference peacefully
under a rule of law today we can look
across the country and around the world
and see anger and fear and places many
of you have been stationed before a
rising tide of hatred and extremism and
political violence
it's more important than ever that we
come together around the principle of
American democracy regardless of our
political backgrounds
we must not succumb to the poisonous
politics of difference and division must
never allow ourselves to be pulled apart
by Petty manufactured grievances
one of the families of 9 11 victims
think about speech in Alaska here to
respond tunnel to Towers Foundation
chairman CEO Frank Siller he lost his
brother on 9 1101 along with Fox News
contributor Joey Jones Frank
um you can add to that the al-Qaeda five
and and we don't have to turn this into
a death penalty debate but the idea that
they'd want to cut a deal with them and
prevent them from getting ultimate
Justice is unbelievable to me but your
thoughts on the president's response
today if you could even understand uh
and get through uh or maybe interpret
what it was he was trying to say
so on a day like today which is such a
sad day for my family and so many other
families that lost a loved one 22 years
ago you would think that a president
would bring some comfort to 9 11
families and to speak of unity and speak
of making sure that we're going to keep
this country safe against people that
are trying to kill us then and I
guarantee you're still trying to kill us
now that some of them are coming over
our borders and it was uh disturbing to
watch him and and his remarks and the
way that he was uh his administration
was boasting about a a 20 a 40 billion
dollar deal with the Sony with Sodis uh
you know for infrastructure and I mean
it's that not only just tone deaf it's
disturbing because it's almost like they
don't care they just don't care and uh
you know America we got to protect
America because as great Heroes that
went there and died on that day like my
brother ran through the Brooklyn Battery
Tunnel with his gear on his back a
firefighter wife five kids what a
sacrifice he made and the guys like you
have uh Joey Joey Jones on here and Joey
gave his body for our country went to
war because what happened 9 11 3 000
people died on 9 11 3 000 have died
since 9 11 with 9 11 illnesses and how
about the 7 000 men and women that died
because of the global war on terror we
that's what we should be talking about
and that's who we should be honoring
today and Joey Jones uh you did eight
years of service you worked with the
explosive ordinance disposal as a
disposable explosive ordinance disposal
technician you were in Iraq and
Afghanistan separate tours in
Afghanistan you're responsible for
disarming and destroying over 80 IEDs
saving you know God knows how many
thousands of lives that's thousands of
pounds of of explosives and August 6
2010 you stepped on and initiated an IED
you lost both your legs above the knee
severe damage to your right forearm both
wrists and you know what are your
thoughts because you know what there's
there's so many that suffer like you
have and others that never came home
yeah first of all 80 IEDs had a teammate
right beside me the whole time he could
have uh he could have lost his life at
any moment and when I lost my legs it
killed Corporal Daniel Greer standing
right beside me trying to protect me
um yeah the war on terror was terrible
it was atrocious I just got back from a
hunting trip with a fireman a police
officer and four other combat wounded
veterans and the truth is two of us were
wounded but the other two were hurting
the other two have invisible wounds
their heart hurts They Carried their
friends back in bags that one's a silver
star recipient and the other one should
be the legacy of 911 will continue to
hurt for generations to come all we ask
of those that represent us those that
get to make decisions is to be honest
make the best decision they can and and
have accountability when they screw up
so when you look at Joe Biden I can't
help but think about the fact that you
know Flight 93 was headed towards DC
regular Americans took that plane down
sacrificed their life ultimately to save
people in DC to save our elected
representatives but today our elected
president couldn't make it back to D.C
or New York or Pennsylvania just to say
some words show some respect but I guess
that makes sense he's looking to win
votes of generations that weren't alive
when 9 11 happened two years ago he
botched ending the war he doesn't care
yeah it's scary at times uh the letter T
the number two the letter T dot org
tunnel to Towers 11 bucks a month if you
can commit it that's how they continue
that great work thank you both Joey
thank you good to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else